all right so yeah thank you all for for
coming to my talk uh and um I hope
you're as enthusiastic about on demand
Logistics as I am um so we're going to
be talking today about uh solving
optimization models for on demand
delivery uh using python o tools and
some decision Ops tooling that will sort
of be in the background making things
work a little bit um if you want to
follow along uh this uh talk all the
materials for it are on that GitHub URL
right down at the bottom here um so you
can just go to github.com ranj O'Neal
that's my GitHub username 2023 python or
Pi dat Global orderup uh and you can
find all the code that I'm going to run
in there uh you can also just look at it
afterward um but anything that that uh
I'm doing in here you should be able to
maybe hopefully follow along
with all right
so uh again my name is Ryan I'm CTO and
co-founder of next move I spent the last
uh bunch of years now working in on
demand Logistics uh my background is in
operation research uh and before that I
was a software engineer for a while um I
think I've been using python about 17
years off and on now um and been really
excited to see sort of how the adoption
of data science uh in Python uh has
exploded over the last many years and
also how that is really moving into
optimization python is becoming sort of
the de facto language for a lot of
optimization modeling um and so that's
what we're going to be looking at today
uh with these specific
applications um so if you're coming to
this talk sorry I'm having a little bit
of a lag with the slides so just bear
with me on that a little bit during the
talk anyway um You probably have uh one
of two interests one is you are uh going
to start working on some of these models
uh you need to maybe do some scheduling
or some forecasting um or some uh uh
routing or or similar things like maybe
order fulfillment or assignment or
resource allocation uh and maybe you
don't quite know where to start or you
want to sort of understand how these
things play together in an onim and
logistic setting um so those are really
the couple of audiences that this this
talk is geared at uh the things that
you're going to come away from it with
are a sense of how sort of the three
what I think of as minimum viable models
of on demand uh work together and what
they are uh and how you can model them
using a single tool in this case we're
going to use or tools because it applies
nicely to all of these things there are
lots of other things that you could use
um and how to sort of work together with
these things so that's what you'll come
away with um
[Music]
I'm using a single tool here uh because
in my opinion an optimization solver and
modeling library is really the most
important part of your stack if you're
doing decision modeling I think of it
like a Swiss army knife and so one of
the things I like about this giving this
particular kind of uh a talk is that
we're going to be using that same
technology and same library in three
very different ways and the first way is
uh forecasting which is not something
typically see an optimization solver
used for it's not the only way to do
forecasting obviously um but it is how
we're going to do it here so if you just
had a single Hammer that you needed to
reach for uh an optimization Library an
optimization solver is one that you
could be quite successful with and so we
should all uh pick them
up uh for the example today uh we're
going to pretend that we are part of
what we call the farm share company uh
we are a consumer delivery service we
deliver carrots and beets and lettu uses
to uh vegetable oriented people um and
we're moving from say manual Silo
processes where we're using a lot of
spreadsheets or maybe we've got like a
Monopoly board or a risk board and we're
sort of moving pieces around to figure
out how to run our operations uh and we
want to move to some sort of a
technology platform and and have tighter
integration between these things so the
the three primary things that we have to
do are we need to forecast demand for
carrots we need to schedule our carrot
delivery vehicles and we need to do
route planning for our carrots um to get
them to the actual end uh carrot
consumers for any one of these things
there's different cadences we could do
these at um we'll just sort of assume
that we forecast maybe once a month once
a week something like that uh and we
schedule sort of in tandem with the
forecast to figure out how many drivers
we need at each block given driver
availability uh and we might route plan
daily but you could take any of these
things and extend them to different
cadences it just changes how you think
about the model and how you use
it all right so we've got these three
different models how are we going to
solve them um like I mentioned earlier
we are going to use o tools for all of
these but within o tools and part of the
reason that it is interesting to us uh
is that it is a a u uh a multi- paradigm
Library it is a hybrid solver and a
multi Paradigm Library it supports
linear programming mix iner programming
or if you're under 40 it might be linear
optimization it makes an end
optimization um it also supports
constraint programming s satisfiability
and local search um so we'll use all of
those things today um and what we're
going to use for our forecasting is
actually what's called lad or least
absolute Dev deviations regression least
absolute deviations regression uh which
is a linear programming uh model and for
our shift scheduling we're going to use
mixed ner programming or mixed iner
optimization or tools also comes with a
its own scheduling interface which you
could use as well and I put that in the
exercises at the end U and then we're
going to use o tools's uh default
routing um solver which is based on
their constraint programming and
satisfiability uh and local search
technology and again you could also use
something like Mix N programming or you
could use a commercial option like next
route for next move or something like
that for for any for for the
routing um so in a production
environment um this is how these three
things typically work together we
typically forecast some sort of demand
uh and that produces targets that
combined with targets produces an actual
uh U scheduling targets that we need to
hit um so for example we might our
forecast might tell us we're going to
have 50 deliveries to to do during 2 and
4 p.m. on Friday and then what we want
to do from that is say given the amount
of demand that I have and available
drivers and my economic targets which is
essentially orders per driver or orders
per driver
hour how can I optimally schedule um to
to be right where I want to be I don't
want to have too many drivers because
that's expensive and I don't want to
have too few drivers because that gives
bad service so that's what we do with
scheduling once we actually have drivers
on the ground um or maybe the day before
or the week before depending on how we
run our operations we also need to come
up with routes and the question was just
can I repost the link here and yes I
absolutely can so just give me a second
to do
that and hopefully this comes up in the
chat this is my first time using air me
so you can follow along there and that
has the requirements.txt you only need
the one the one module which is O tools
all right and so the the routing model
there is um what will allow us to say
what sequence do I put different stops
in uh you know where do I go first
second third and who is doing those
actual routes so it's really an
assignment and uh sequencing problem is
is what vehicle routing
is so we'll start for for each of these
models what we'll do and again this is
going to be a little quick um but we'll
what we'll do is uh we'll just go
briefly through the structure of the
model which might include some math it
might include some some business um
operational things uh and then we'll
watch we'll look at it in in a in a uh
an actual script which is what you'll
find in the in the GitHub so first let's
look at our forecasting
model um I have generated synthetic data
which you can find in the GitHub it's
under forecast input. Json and what it
is um is a sort of rep data that I think
is representative of stuff that we see
in on demand delivery and so this is uh
daily data Broken Out by Meal Time and
so meal time is essentially morning no
uh midday evening and night four four
hour blocks um and what we can see here
and again I've generated this data so I
know exactly what it is um but it's very
spiky along uh the course of the week so
Monday and Tuesday are different from
Saturday and Sunday uh and it's very
different from Meal Time and there are
some seasonality Trends in here there's
also uh an overall daily Trend it's
increasing in volume and so we might it
would be fairly normal of us to get data
like this from operations and then say
give a forecast that sort of looks into
the future to help me figure out what's
going to going on and we might look at
this and say like gosh I don't know is
there a trend it looks like there's a
trend what's the trend I don't know
um if we look a little bit more recently
so this would be the last 28 days and
you can see here I generated the data on
November 14 so it's a little dated
already um this is split up by meal time
again um and you know there's there's
looks to be some overall Trends but it's
a little hard to sort of separate out
exactly what's going on um and so we're
going to use loud regression against
this um to try and sort of tease out uh
the the variance that is explained by
each of the different features um that
we look at and um project into the
future a few
weeks so why lad regression uh there's a
couple of reasons um one is that it's
robust to outliers and so it's a
regression that I think is underused uh
and so here we have sort of a
demonstration of what that means um
let's say we've got this uh curve is our
actual predicted uh this is our fit
fitted line um and these blue dots are
actuals uh what we can see here is that
this dot is uh one um unit away from the
prediction and this other dot here is
two units away traditionally if we're
using something like least squares uh
this purple will be squared and
therefore has a a much bigger impact on
the fit of the model than this uh single
orange bar and so what this means is
that least squares is actually less
robust than something like lad
regression to outliers it can the
outliers in the data can can um uh
impact the fit of the model much more
they have a bigger they have an outsize
impact on on the coefficients that the
model gives us back so that's one reason
that lad is a nice type of regression um
it's also customizable in interesting
ways so if you're using an optimization
solver to actually do your forecasting
you can do things um yes lad is
equivalent to L1 Norm that's exactly
correct yep yep um yeah you're just uh
essentially instead of squaring uh these
lines you're just summing them up it's
like how how far away is
um um and so if if we're actually
building our uh regression model using
an optimization U solver we can
customize that model in any way that we
want right and so I might be able to do
interesting things like do Epsilon and
sensitivity right and and stuff like
that which is actually really hard to do
with a pre-formulated um uh uh
solver um all right and another is we
can model as a linear program which is
convenient for the talk today because
we're using uh or tools to solve all of
these things so let's look a little bit
at what the model looks like um so if
we're coming to regression from an
optimization perspective this is what
that model looks like we're trying to
minimize uh essentially the sum of a
bunch of residuals and those residuals
are just applied they have some Norm
applied to them which could be sort of
any valid Norm um now typically Le
squares that's the L2 Norm uh but in lad
all we're doing is we're saying we're
going to replace that with the L1 Norm
it's otherwise other than that it's the
same model where it gets interesting is
if we now split that out what we can see
here is this is the the way the least
squares model works on the left and
there's a nice um closed form analytical
solution to that particular model I can
just plug it the inputs into an equation
getting an output and I I theorize that
this is probably why we actually all
grew up using least squares because it's
just very easy to implement I don't
actually have to use an algorithm to
implement it I can just use you know a
least squares equation essentially
um if we then go to the right instead
and look at LAD regression what that
really becomes is just this absolute
value right this L1 Norm um and that
turns into a model which looks like what
is below essentially um we're trying to
minimize the sum of these residuals
where it's the absolute value and so we
have to introduce these other variables
which we call Z um to say to to do that
absolute value part and this is what
turns it into a linear program and now
we have to use linear programming or
linear optimization to solve it and so I
think this is might be part of why um
had has less adoption in general but
we're going to we're going to do it
anyway um so I showed you the data a
little bit ago um on the right is a
dolly uh impression of of of a bunny
solving live progression which I thought
was interesting um there is there's
nothing particularly new in this
implementation I just stole it from a
paper by Rob vanderby the slides are in
the GitHub so you can find that link
there if you're interested in the paper
it's pretty cool um and so I'm basically
doing exactly what he's doing and again
I designed the data so I know what the
features are and they are the an offset
a daily Trend seasonality solar cycle
and a weekly Trend so we're just going
to plug that right into the model um and
see what
happens all right so let's do our
forecasting speedrun hopefully we're
doing okay on
time all right so first let's let's look
at what our data looks like um this is
again generated data and I just have
created a Json where um every you know
4H hour block during a time frame uh it
has a demand and it's you know morning
midday evening or night and that's what
our input looks like again that's the
GitHub you can play with that if you
want um in the forecast repo there or
forecast directory there's also a
main.py which has the ORS model in it um
and the important parts of it are
here uh where what we're doing is
essentially creating um a variable for
each observation which is the fitted
value and then a variable for um that
absolute value right and
so let me go up here again here we go so
this is a an continuous variable which
is the fitted value that the the
optimizer is going to produce and then
the actual residual is
um the another uh continuous variable
which has a minimum of zero and so you
remember from the previous slide uh what
we did was we said you know we're going
to have ax um minus B for each one of
these things and uh I want to take the
absolute value of that and it requires
another uh continuous variable and then
what we add our constraints where we say
that residual has to be greater than or
equal to either the actual minus the
fitted or the fitted minus the actual
and this is the whole purpose here this
is this is everything this is the whole
reason it's a linear
program everything else is just you know
constructing the data for that um so
it's really just sort of data munging uh
we minimize the sum of the residuals we
call solve and or tools we are using in
this case the skip Optimizer but you
could plug in a different linear
programming solver here uh and it would
work pretty well um and then we just
pull the data out and that's really it
um so when we run it let me go into our
forecast what I'm going to do is just um
push that into uh next move and run it
there and so now it's run pushed into a
remote
environment and I'm going to run it
remotely with that input.
Json and uh it'll just give me back in a
few seconds um forecast which we can
look
at okay and so here what we have is
another Json blob that it gave me back
and um if I go up far enough I can see
way back when um that there will
be um demand so this is observed demand
data for a particular day and block and
then forecasted Demand right and so what
we're expecting is that not to exactly
match so that's that's good um and then
if I go down to the bottom I can see
that I have
forecasted into the future from when the
model wasun run which was uh Based on
data from November 14 all right so
that's my forecast uh let me now go back
to our slides so if I plot this um this
is the output that I get um and it's
interesting because you know given that
I designed the data I know exactly what
the best model is so this is really the
best we should be able to do um and so
we can see here we're going along and
we've we've split this out um by meil
time and then we're forecasting to the
Future so the the orange are the actuals
uh and the bars are the residuals and we
can see we have this forecast going
forward and we used all tools to do it
all well and good all right so now that
we have our forecast data the next
question is how do we
schedule so let's look at our scheduling
mod um so there's two inputs to
scheduling um one is is uh targets and
so these are economic targets that we
set as the operator and the other is um
availability of our drivers and so
when we're setting economic targets uh
it's fairly typical to sort of underst
Staff during low periods low volume
periods so you can maintain service
levels sorry to over staff um and to try
and uh essentially uh make more money
during high volume um higher volume
leads to less variability uh means you
can be more efficient and so on so forth
um so what I've arbitrarily done is said
I want three order uh orders per driver
hour uh during morning and night four
during midday and uh five at evening and
so that's that's given my operations I
think that'll be um a pretty good sort
of uh uh Target to
meet and our objective for scheduling in
this case is just going to be uh minim
minimizing some penalty of overstaffing
and understaffing and those could be
those can and probably are typically
different
penalties um you might want to to over
staff for example on uh the day after
Thanksgiving when you need to do a lot
of deliveries
um so or you might want TOA staff during
other certain times depending on sort of
how your economic uh conditions or your
business is going and so on so forth um
all right so this is the scheduling
model that we're going to look at and
this if you look at it is a mix in of
programming program or as binary
variables and just briefly going through
the math of it um we're going to
minimize the penalties of oversupplying
and under supplying for every hour that
we are over supplied or under supplied
in the output of the scheduling model
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to add a constraint which is that
the supply that's this sub subh here is
the sum of every uh bu everybody every
worker that I've assigned to work during
a particular hour given their in given
their um availability so if I if I
select a shift then that goes into the
pool of Supply right and so that's
that's what is what is going to allow us
to see what the difference is between
scheduled and um Target uh supply and
demand and so so here we have these uh O
and U variables for over Supply and
unders Supply and we basically do the
same thing we did in the last Model
where we say the over Supply is greater
than equal to um the amount of uh demand
minus Supply and the under Supply is the
reverse and then every W variable is
binary every worker is either scheduled
or not um all right so if
we now go into the actual code for this
uh we'll go back here and look at the
data all right so we have penalties here
so these are penalties per hour of over
Supply and under Supply so in my
particular case I'm just assuming that
we um we are going to penalize under
Supply more than over Supply but that
could be different in different use
cases um so it's a 1.5 to 5 ratio uh and
then I've got um generated data where I
say you know when are different workers
available um and so you know this worker
says they're available between what um
you know, 1500 and 1,800 and that's an
entire shift so if I schedule them I'm
going to give them the entire shift and
your operations might not match this so
again this is one of many possible
scheduling
models
um and then I've got required workers
and again this is just a target of or of
this is from the forecast and the
targets so during this block I want 13
during this other block I want 32 if we
go to our schedule
directory all right this is in the
repost so you should be able to run it
um you can look through the code and
it's basically the same sort of
structure as the last Model the
important parts um are here where we
extend the objective function um so this
is where we multiply the penalties by
the over and underage amounts and this
is actually where we say um what is the
over and under amount under uh Supply
amount for each
hour um and that's basically the whole
model so I won't go into it uh too much
but you can you can can look through the
code and see it there um and if we go
into this repository I will push that
into a production environment and part
of the reason I want to do this is we
have these nice little
visuals um that we can uh bring
up uh in the cloud environment where we
can actually see what the input output
looks like visually so I just ran it
that input through our Cloud environment
um and I will go into our apps and I can
see here we have a shift scheduling with
o tools uh model which I just
ran and this was the input which you
should recognize and here we have blocks
and availability and then if I go to the
result I can see I have optimized uh
schedules um based on on on those inputs
all right so final model we're going to
go through is a routing model I need to
go back into slideshow
mode oops that is backward here we go oh
and if we plot that this is what we
actually actually get um so here the red
is the design hired or essentially
demand or targets uh and then blue is is
scheduled after that
optimization and and given the uh
assumptions in the data this is optimal
for that particular instance so you
can't really do better than
that all right finally we'll go through
our routing model and this one's pretty
quick
um the basic premise here is um you know
we're trying to minimize drive time and
and and cost which could be time it
could be t uh uh distance um it could be
some function of those things it could
be earliness lateness it really just
depends on your business case um and
we're trying to have good service levels
right so mist or L deliveries INF
furiate drivers so we've got a bunch of
demand um in in this case we're
delivering from a warehouse but these
could also be pick up and drop off
problems from restaurants or something
like that um how do we do this most
efficiently and also sort of Hit the
service targets that uh users have given
us or we have given our
users um the way that we're going to do
this again using or Tools in their
python interface um we're going to use
their uh routing uh Library which if you
look at it um is really just a uh an API
wrapper around their cpat solver so it
gives you access to all of those um
underlying constraint programming
Primitives um and under the hood it's
constraint programming satisfiability
local search um it's interesting uh
implementation and you can find uh
information about how it's implemented
in these these papers that are linked in
the slides all right so briefly our
routing
speedrun this is what our data is going
to look like so we've got vehicles um
we're going to use a centralized Depot
here um there's a a location that they
all start and end at uh and they all
have different vehicle or they all have
the same vehicle capacities um again
we're just doing carrot delivery here so
that makes sense uh we've got a bunch of
stops to service um they take different
amounts of carrots um and we've got
eight vehicles and they're all identical
and that might not be the case in your
particular use case but um that is
here um if we look at the model um all
I've done here is just adapt uh an or
tools example which is their vrp
capacity example directly into the
structure that we have um and so this
code is all just ripped right out of
there um just using our our particular
input structure and you know what it
does is essentially has the it has these
callbacks uh which update uh finite
domain variables inside of the search so
as the engine makes uh decisions it will
use these call backs to to trigger
changes between them and so that's how
we deal with things like capacity this
is essentially a capacity constraint
it's done through call back mechanisms
uh and it's the same with um distance so
there's a distance call back which when
it ties two things together go from A to
B it it calls this call back and says
how far away are they or um how long
does it take to get from one to another
and so that's that's basically the model
um and everything else is just you know
calling the standard oral stuff all
right so if we run
this again I want to run this in the
cloud environment uh so that um I'm
going to push it so that I get a nice
visual now it's pushed and I'm going to
run it uh and wait for the output that
should take about 10 seconds I think
that's what I put as the uh the default
uh and while that is running uh we'll
just go over here and go back into the
cloud
environment and
look at our
apps delivery routing power
tools
runs and here I can see this was the
input and so this Json should look
familiar and here are the optimized
RS all right so back into slideshow mode
so in summary um forecasting scheduling
and routing are sort of the three
starter models uh that you need to
operate in on demand delivery there's a
lot of other models um but if you're if
you're going to do this this is really
the The Three core ones um they're sort
of like the the French mother sauces um
to
Logistics um optimization underlies many
or most decision models uh if you are
using a forecasting library or a routing
library or really anything optimization
is under the hood there and you can just
ACC access it directly through tools
like go tools um there's other tools you
can do that with too many have python
interfaces so it's worth uh exploring
these and understanding that Universe um
and if you don't know where to start you
can just take that repository and that's
your that's a starting point where you
can at least get a get um up and going
with um I also included some exercises
that are that I thought were interesting
um so if you really want to to go deep
here you can uh use the same input
output data with a different forecasting
tool like profit Uber I think released
one called orbit recently there's also
camax and things like that um so it's
interesting to compare these um one size
does not fit all for forecasting uh
another good exercise would be to change
the scheduling model to use or our tools
is apis instead of a mixer programming
program and just sort of see how that
works and what it does uh and then I'd
suggest also trying a different vehicle
routing solver there's a bunch of them
out there you could try the one from
next move which is called Next route you
could formulate a MIP um if you're
interested reach out to me and I can
send some resources on that and that's
all I have so thank you so much for your
time and attention uh and I'll take any
questions you
[Music]
have great thank you so much Ryan that
was very that was fascinating so um yeah
I don't we don't see any questions in
the Q&A but there are some comments um
and I guess the first one is um uh you
answered that
lad quantile
not yeah uh that's an interesting
question so um I think you could use
quanti regression in this context um
obviously that would make the the model
a little more challenging um but I don't
think there's any reason you can't use
quantal regression here and that would
uh be a sensible thing to do
great um thank you um we have the next
comment is can you explain the 4A
features uh they are monthly or weekly
question mark I refer to the
frequencies um I'm not entirely this I
think this question goes a little bit
over my head um but I I
think I think I think what it's asking
is to explain the feature yeah okay I
understand I think so if I go backward a
little bit um we had these
features that were here okay so the
offset is um given the data just what is
the starting point right so if the you
know if you had a line that was just
starting at zero and at a y-v value of
100 that would be 100 right um daily
Trend you know if we look
at um this we can see that it's sort of
increasing over time and so that's that
would account for that if I if I just
stuck a a straight line on here that
would really be daily Trend um and then
there was solar cycle uh seasonality um
I'll refer you to the Rob Vander by
paper a little bit more about that you
if you look in the python code you'll
see some weird stuff involving signs and
cosiness and that's what the solar cycle
uh Trend was um that really is there
for when it's warm out people behave
differently um is is really why that's
there um but you you we could also use
things like months um or uh for instance
School Seasons might be really uh
applicable in something like meal
delivery if you're in a college town so
it kind of just depends um and then the
last ones were
weekly um and I can uh reach out if you
want to reach out to me I can send some
more information on some of this stuff
but yeah if you look um this uh what
you'll see here is we we have a better
split out by day and there's a certain
amount of the variance that is explained
by it being a Monday versus a Tuesday
versus a Wednesday uh and so there I
think those were all the the different
uh parts that were were included in here
um you you'll see a lot of different
features ort of make sense in different
scenarios in on demand Logistics
depending on the the business model and
how they operate